ja wie ist die Lage die Lage ist warm
würde ich erstmal sagen ich bin sehr
wärmeempfindlich und immer wenn der
Sommer kommt dann leid ich wie eine Sau
dann ertrage ich das alles nicht und
leider wohne ich unterm Dach und leider
habe ich auch mein Büro unterm Dach also
ich bin dementsprechend dagegen nicht
gewatmet und Klimaanlagen bringen es
einfach nicht ich habe schon überlegt ob
ich den eschrank aufmache aber das
bringt auch nicht Christina bringst du
mal bitte auch ein Kaffee ja gerne gerne
gerne komm hier so schön lecker ja warum
hast du dann ausgerechnet Büro und
Wohnung unterm Dach gewählt gute Frage
ich trinke er mal wohlin leckeren
kaffeelatte MAK ich hoffe ist nicht warm
der ist ja schon kalt Christina hör mal
ich habe Gäste hier im Haus jetzt kommt
die Lise wieder durch nee Frage war
warum unter Dach gut am Dach da hat man
nur noch den Himmel übicht das finde ich
ganz schön ist mir besser als wenn man
die Hölle untersich hat also insofern
war das das erste Kriterium dann
natürlich nur mit fahrstuh in meinem
Alter schaffe ich das einfach nicht mehr
die Treffen hochzusteigen und
da wo ich wohne ist eben sehr schön ne
also Sonnenuntergang und so weiter hier
ist ja auch schön Sommer ist es dann
halt nicht zum aushalten aber ja ich
hätte gerne im Keller irgendwie im Bett
vielleicht richtig mir dann noch was
Keller mit Terrasse und Dachfenster aber
dies Dachgeschoss ist auch immer so eine
Sache dass man sagt als junger Mensch
einmal ein Dachgeschoss in Berlin das
ist es überhaupt ne das ist also für
penthus viele erstrebenswert und das
war's für mich genauso heute würde ich
mir das vielleicht noch mal überlegen
aber eigentlich fühle ich mich ganz wohl
hier mhm aber wieso bist du
hinsempfindlich als ein Bühnenkünstler
ich meine du stehst doch ständig im
Rampenlicht im wahsten Sinne des Wortes
und das ist heiß ich hatte das ja auch
schon so das war so dass ich Auftritte
hatte wo ich umzieharien machen musste
das heißt es waren wirklich 40° in welch
welchen Zelten auf dem Land und da bin
ich dann nicht mehr in die Klamotten
gekommen das heißt mein Pianist hat sich
vorne in Wolf gefiedelt gespielt und ich
bin einfach nicht gekommen ne weil ich
immer noch in ein Kostüm drin hing und
so weiter musste ich mich dann umziehen
und klebte praktisch
von daher ja ich ertrag das einfach
nicht aber ich halt schon seit 30 Jahren
aus das stimmt ne nun t Turnieren wir ja
immer im Herbst oder im Frühjahr das
heißt da ist es dann nicht so heiß im
Sommer würde ich dann auch gar nicht so
viel unterwegs sein wollen das heißt bei
dir trifft das im wahrsten Sinne des
Wortes zu Kreativität ist mehr
Transpiration als
Inspiration es ist beides ich meine
daraus ergibt sich ja auch wieder was
Kreativität ist ja erstmal
ist vorhanden die wird einem ja mit den
Genen gegeben denke ich mal ne wenn man
so ein unruhiger Geist ist und man sagt
ja immer man das sind menschliche Muster
oder sowas irgendein Muster das habe ich
noch nicht ergründet warum ich kreativ
bin oder warum ich mich so immer noch
auch jetzt immer noch auf die Bühne
stellen muss und Dinge erzählen muss ich
habe einfach Spaß dran vielleicht ist es
das Spaßfaktor sehr hoch geschrieben
immer noch vor 30 Jahren fing es an als
ich los gelegt habe und dann habe ich
gesagt ich mach das zum Spaß und der
Spaß ist immer noch vorhanden wird aber
immer Schwier weil das ganze Geschäft
einem da immer ein Strich durch die
Rechnung macht nicht weil ich ja auch
ein paar Leute beschäftige und so weiter
und da immer mein Auge drauf habe damit
das relativ gut funktioniert und es ist
ja auch nicht mehr so einfach zu händeln
wie noch vor 20 oder 10 Jahren oder so
ne aber ist es nicht so dass man heute
wieder als Bühnenkünstler eigentlich
ganz gut zurecht kommen kann es gibt ja
so viel Comedians in Anführungszeichen
hat ich ja so früher war das ja immer
Kabarettisten ja und da musste man
Kabarettist sein ich sag mal ein Komiker
auf Bühne auch die die hallfen ist ja
als Kabarettist auf die Bühne gegangen
der hat ja auf der Bühne nicht das
gemacht was er im Fernsehen gemacht hat
und heute gibt es mehr so die Comedians
die auch wirklich Programme ja gut der
dID ist ja jetzt in so einem Alter
irgendwo da kann er alles machen da kann
er das auch so titulieren es ist
tatsächlich so das früher ging es 16 15
mit Kabarett los dann gab es diese
blödler Runde ne da möch mal sagen
vielleicht zählt Heinz Erd noch dazu
einer der frühen dann war der Otto
Walkes irgendwann da der war der erste
der solistisch dann irgendwie hallenfol
gemach der hat aber Hallen der hat ja
nur hallenprogramme e aber der ist auch
in kleinpogramm aufgetreten früher und
dann gab's die instburg und Co das waren
die sogenannten blödler und ich bin die
Generation danach das heißt es war immer
so eine Mischung aus ein bisschen
zeitkritisch sein aber auch dann das
Ganze zu verblödeln und war insofern
auch in Kreisen der Kabarettisten immer
so äh Trottel was will denn der hier und
so weiter was hat denn der zu erzählen
und irgendwann wurde dann die Sparte
Comedy dar raus
die ja mittlerweile so viele komedianten
gibt dass man mit dem ignorieren gar
nicht mehr mitkommt ich frage mich
manchmal gibt's denn irgendwann noch
Publikum die das dann auch sehen es
teilen sich im Augenblick 50.000 Komiker
5000 Hallen sage ich mal übers Jahr
verteilt ne was ja eine schöne
Entwicklung letztendlich ist aber wir
brauchen ja auch noch Publikum also
bitte Casting zum Publikum finde ich ja
nicht schlecht also ist das wirklich so
dass wenn man seine tneen plant das ein
Problem ist da ist schon der da ist
schon der und wie komme ich und dann es
ist tatsächlich so weil als guter du
musst vorausschauend arbeiten das heißt
du bist meinwgen in Münster oder in Köln
irgende Halle gerade Köln ist ja die
Hochburg ja da spielen dann an einem
Abend 20 Leute und das aber jeden Tag ne
das heißt wenn dann sag mal Leute die
sehr gut gehen wie Mario bartgrade oder
sowas und du spielst ein Tag danach dann
hast die Arschkarte gezogen das ist
einfach so da kommt keiner ja weil die
Leute ja auch nicht nur begrenzte Mittel
haben mehr oder weniger dann kommt's
natürlich darauf an im Laufe der Zeit
hat man sicher seinen Fankreis erspielt
das sind also auf diese Leute kann man
bestimmt bauen die kommen dann auch
immer wieder und bringen dann auch ihre
Leute mit aber daran muss man immer
arbeiten irwo dass man Sachen macht halt
hier auch dann äh ja dich auch populär
machen mehr oder weniger das heißt du
musst immer so ein bisschen gucken wo
ist der Mainstream und wo ist das was du
vielleicht auch erzählen willst oder was
dir wichtig ist oder so ne das heißt das
ist wirklich deine Passion na es gibt ja
diesen schönen Satz Glück im Spiel und
Geld für die Liebe das finde ich das
ideale das geht ja auch so es ist es ist
ä wenn man so nennen möchte ein bisschen
Passion klar ich bin ja nun mal auch äh
äh oder versuche auch natürlich
kommerziell zu sein cherweise sonst hast
du keine Partner mehr ir das musst du
alles selber machen aber was ist
kommerziell ich war noch mal wichtig ist
dass die Leute dich als Typ mögen dass
sie sagen der Typ der andere erzählt
zwar auch sowas ab von dem höre ich mir
das lieber an oder so ist n immer ein
bisschen albern wenn sie sagen Tag Luise
auch wieder unterwegs ja also mein alter
ego Luise kuschinski dann sagst du ja
Tag blöd Mann da freut er sie lacht sich
tot habe ich sogar schon in der
Verkehrskontrolle gehabt irgendwie also
die haben mir einen guten Dienst gemacht
die B auch ganz ich habe auch nichts
getrunken ja ich habe da nur die Scheibe
runter gemacht habe gesagt was willst du
denn hier und der hat sich kaputt
gelacht der Typ ne D sagt er geh ich
komm mal rüber hier Lise sitz hier und
so ja ich meine das ist auch wieder ein
Vorteil bist du denn ich sag mal jetzt
zufriedener weil du hast ja lange Jahre
auch davon gelebt aber jetzt bist du ja
auch durch viele RTL Sendung viele
Fernsehauftritte viel populärer als
früher viel bekannter Luise Koschinski
ist auch so ein alter ego was ich glaube
jeder in Deutschland kennt ist das mehr
Last oder mehr Spaß
äh es ist beides aber es ist eigentlich
mehr Spaß da steht nicht mehr der Olmer
auf die Bühne steht Luise kusinski und
die rufen auch Lise ich will ein Kind
von dir ja wie sollen das gehen ja ich
habe Angebote also als Frau das ist
unglaublich es ist ein Thema immer noch
ein Thema man sieht es nicht umsonst bei
vielen Kollegen dies Thema mann frraau
mann Freundin und so weiter ich dachte
schon vor 10 Jahren als ich oder 15 als
ich das gemacht habe das hält fünf
Sommer und dann ist das vorbei aber im
Gegenteil geht nur
ja durch das ist doch alles erzählt aber
wobei er wiederum muss man sagen ihm
wirklich zugute halten das
perfektioniert hat in der Form wie er es
verkauft das macht er großartig weil
viele andere Kollegen brauchen dreimal
so viel Tex er bekmt mit dem Drittel
Text aus weil er das alles wiederholt
noch mal wiederholt ist nur die Attitüde
und die reicht ja ja und deswegen finde
ich Leute großartig die mit nichts aber
mit nur ein paar
Worten die sowas machen 3 Minuten oder
gar nicht reden und die Leute lachen
sich glise Kinski ist so eine Figur die
bra eigentlich NS zu sagen die brauchen
nur blöd man Pullover hoch Nabel sieht
und mehr nicht dann lachen die Leute
Minuten lang das sensationell also von
daher brauch ich da gar kein Text ist
das auch eine Figur dieser ökonomisch
ist also nicht so textlastig ich finde
wir reden sowieso so viel im Interview
auch und dann vor allem auf der Bühne
was wollen wir den noch erzählen den
Leuten es geht nur um Attitüden das
heißt nonverbale Kommunikation im
weitesten Sinne ein Augenschlag ein
Blick ein Zeichen keine Ahnung sagt doch
alles ja das finde ich auch mal gut man
ein Programm zu machen in dem nur 5
Minuten Text drin vorkommen der Rest
einfach so sich die Worte gut aufheben
die nächste Herausforderung also guten
Abend muss sein schön hier zu sein muss
sein und in Köln muss man sagen ich
finde Köln gut ist muss man auch sagen
in Düsseldorf umgekehrt ja dann hat man
schon und zum Schluss der Schluss muss
gut sein als ganze Programm kann scheiße
sein die letzten 10 Minuten müssen
sensationell sein dann kriegst Du noch
mal Z Zugaben das ist auch so irgendwie
so eine ja da reagieren die Leute auch
wir erklären zu viel neige ich auch
manchmal zu Z mir mal eine an Mann ich
hasse sie diese
Nichtraucher